Hey, what's going on? Is Bill Burn? It's
time for the Monday morning podcast. I no,
what is it? What am I talking about?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast at [inaudible].
Huh. Huh? I'm just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in to see
how your Goddamn Day is going.
I know lately the podcast has been
a little bit quiet. I understand.
All right.
I was transitioning from one part of the
country to another part of the country.
I didn't have my,
my technologies with me.
Uh,
speaking of technology now these fucking
movies that I want to see right now and
I just don't have the God damn time.
I want to see that Mr. Rogers movie.
I want to see mission
impossible and I want to see a,
there was some movie called
eighth grade where they were like,
this is what it's like to
be an eighth grader in the,
during the social media time.
I'm like, oh, I should see that.
You know, cause I need to relate
to some sorts, Pete young people.
So my jokes keep working with them. I
mean, not eighth graders, but you know,
in a blink of an eye, the way I'm aging,
that kid will be in fucking college,
right? You can't ignore the
youth, the ignore the you,
you grow old with your fucking crowd.
And then next thing you know,
you're doing shows at three in the
afternoon on a little fucking booze cruise
going around the marina,
you know,
five foot two wiser blue,
but oh,
what those five foots could do you singing
that song. Hey had a body, Shane mind.
Yeah,
right up there in some fucking mustard
stain tuxedos yelling at your agent
players to sell tickets at this town.
They ain't happen to make.
Um,
I'll tell you what did happen to me.
This is very embarrassing and
it's of a physical nature.
It's a part of my body.
And this is a time when I feel
everybody has been emoting and,
and we've gotten rid of the shame. So I
just wanted it. Before I tell you this,
I just want to thank all of you
for being considerate and thoughtful of
my feelings during this difficult time.
All right. So my, my
sciatic nerves came back.
Oh, it came back with a vengeance because
I didn't keep going to them as suits to
keep fucking making sure
you know, that, you know,
whatever the fuck happened the first
time didn't happen again and it got all
messed up again.
And uh,
we were trying to figure out what
triggers it and I'm like, well,
flying helicopters, you know, I fly
the smallest one that exists, so this,
there's nothing about it that's has to
do with comfort and all has to do with
weight and balance and get in
the fucking thing off the ground.
As long as you can sit down, they don't
give a shit if you're on a bed of nails.
And I think it's just maybe that, that's
what's aggravating it. She's like,
all right, what else you got? I played
drums. I'll sit there for an hour,
an hour and a trying to figure out how
that cute little Asian girl played good
times, bad times, so
easily, effortlessly, right.
What else do I sit in a writer's room?
I fly in planes and all that type of shit.
And she goes, all right.
And she was listening to and
she just basically told me
and, uh, you know, debt. My problem is,
is I have no ass
all over the years.
I've just sat down so long,
what little ass I had is now gone.
So a bill, Billy, no
Goop, no glucose, right?
Is Al Pachino would say he's got no ass.
Right?
So it's just,
it's just essentially
bones, nerves, veins,
atoris in skin.
There's no muscle tone back there.
I basically have Michael Douglas's ass
in basic instinct, whatever that one was,
where he was like fucking 65
and decided to do the yet.
Remember that was like a big thing
with like white guys back then,
be it happy in an old guy and just
showing your ass Dennis Franz on fucking
Nyp de Bleu, fucking, uh, Michael Douglas
and basic end state,
one of those movies where he was
just fucking throw in chicks around,
which you could never do anymore.
Like it was,
he was beating them and
fucking them at the same time.
And I'll tell you the bride's
back in the day, they loved it.
It was considered a hot seat.
Now a days off. Oh Jesus.
What was that couch made
of? Dead. He bent her over.
Was that fucking made of ostrich for
that's offensive to women in nature,
right?
Yeah.
Now I don't know what you do.
I don't know.
I haven't seen a love seat
in this new progressive time.
I imagine the guy is sitting
there with his hands folded
Eq skills base.
Would it be alright if I
leaned across the table and got
a little closer? Do you? Hi,
I'm offended. Um, anyways, what
am I talking about here? Oh,
so I have to do some fucking squats,
you know,
and I got a bone bruise. I'm
falling apart here. People.
I've got a bone bruise on my left knee
because, uh, my beautiful daughter,
or I'm loving as I'm teaching
her how to play catch.
And we got this giant bag of
these plastic balls, right?
And I think she's right handed,
which I'm not gonna lie to you.
I want her to be a lefty.
You're a lefty.
You can get to the show with an 85 mile
an hour fast ball. We all know it. Okay?
You start throwing right handed.
You gotta come with the guests.
It's gotta be fuck it.
I don't know.
It's gotta be like fucking 102 miles an
hour at this point. So anyways, she just,
she'll pick up two at a time and then
she runs at me and just throws them both
at the same time.
And I just play like goalie and we got
hard wood floors and I was crawling
around on the hardwood on
my knees and uh, I dunno. I,
I thought I fucking towards something,
but thank God.
Yesterday I found out it's just a bone
bruise so it's going away. But um,
yeah, so here's a big deal. I got it.
I have to go on the Internet and I got
to make sure I do my squats right. Okay.
And I have to get my pasty flat ass.
I gotta get some padding back.
There are, evidently this is going
to, it's going to become even worse.
You know what I mean? I've decided
that I'm going to get fucking, uh,
um, I'm gonna, I'm gonna get my ass back.
I've decided that rather than be that
old white guy who has the inflatable
cushion that he fucking sits on,
I can't be that guy.
You know what I mean?
Taking people up in a helicopter,
like looking like a Badass,
like, hang on a second, guys
just fucking may know.
Everybody just loses all confidence.
Does this guy know how to
fly this fucking thing? Um,
anyways, uh, that's my deal. You know,
and I'm also a child of the 80s
and you know who's kidding who?
Let's all be honest.
Nobody did legs in the fucking
eighties unless she wrote bodybuilder.
Everybody just, you barely
even did your back. You know,
everybody was just fucking, everybody
just did like, what are your benching?
What's your bent?
Dodi put up to 25 fucking 36 times.
Yeah.
Kay could try out for the
patch stowed. Right. That's
all it was about. And it was,
I'll tell you, you go to
a fucking gym, all right?
And if you have to bench,
if you're waiting for the [inaudible]
going to stand there like a line at
Starbucks at like eight in the fucking
morning waiting to get on the bench.
But I'll tell you where there's no
fucking, I'll tell you right now with,
there's no line. You go into
the leg room. Oh my God.
It's like walking into a furniture
store. Go ahead buddy. Try them all out.
See which one you like.
Right?
It's like going into lightened leisure.
The purple building.
Does that play still exist?
Um,
I'm making a lot of Boston references
and you probably like, why bill?
Are you a Ho? Oh, you fucking cunt.
The battery thing just fucking beat. Are
you fucking kidding me? I swear to God.
I just can't get a God damn fucking break.
I'm just going to talk to, this
runs out, I guess in 43 seconds.
42 seconds.
I'm talking Boston ship because the uh,
the Yankees, oh, when
they're Yankees come to town.
The Red Sox Yankees stats tonight
and prices and in judges out,
right?
But all they're missing is a hitter
were mentioned missing our star pitcher.
And I needed that guy cause I got,
I got a hundred bucks riding on every
game with these two different Yankee fans.
50 bucks each. I need a price to go
in there and shut those fucking pin.
Stripe comes down.
Now we don't have our and and uh,
not price with the fuck am I talking
about? Uh, the other guy, their prices.
The Guy I need not to fuck up. All
right, I'm back. You know what?
It wasn't a battery issue.
It was,
the memory was full full of me running
my fucking Yap. I'm sitting there saying,
prices out a sale is out.
Is it Chris Sale?
I've only been on the bandwagon
here for the last month. He's out.
He said he had something that's been
building something that's been bothering
him. You know what'd
you get your period? Um,
he can't play fucking a Mike Judge.
Aaron judge is out for the Yankees,
right?
He's standing there like a
fucking Paul Bunyan. I mean,
how do you not hit the
guy? I mean, Jesus Christ,
he's like the size of
the goddamned backstop,
got a bone chip in the palm of his hand.
He's an amazing a guy
that that fucking pig,
all you have to do is throw ball in his
hands and all of a sudden he can't play
a game of baseball.
I mean,
you're talking about a guy who could
literally rip the pillars out of the
fucking parking lot, you know, but then
you hit him in the hand. He's like,
how am I going to play Patty cake?
I can't come out for the red sox series,
but you know, that is the history of
the Yankees. You know what I mean?
You know, they got a lot of free agent
guys and they're all really soft,
just like a,
all their fans out in the bleachers.
All those fatties out there
that do the roll call.
Like that's the big thing in life
fe area and wave at us,
those neck fat fucking
jerk offs out there. Um,
it's unbelievable that you can have a
team that, that's, that's successful,
that they would, they would, uh,
be involved in something. Well,
I just don't get it.
I don't get the fucking why MCA.
I don't get why we have a fucking mascot.
I don't get why we sing sweet Caroline.
I don't,
you know what it is that they're
trying to get rid of the animals.
You know what I mean? I
mean, the Yankees fence,
they borderline doing a fucking musical.
I thought it was an
advertisement for that.
What was that show they
had all those years? Uh,
with the puppets avenue Q.
That's what I thought it was.
I was looking at the scoreboard.
Guns are coming out of that. No,
those are full grown adult males.
A tow yard.
We'll you fuckers by fuel. Would you
roll call lunch. I got to charge up.
Get aligned.
We're going to say your name
until you acknowledge us.
And I know I'm coming down
hard on the Yankee fence.
I realized this is not all of you guys.
This is he fucking 12% of you, um,
with your little gang of baseball fans.
But as much as I do that,
I don't think anything's worse than
watch should fucking do, but do
Buddo Dubar too.
When that song comes on and you see all
those women putting their head on their
boyfriend,
you know what I mean?
That right there,
that moment there is why women in
general are not in positions of power.
They sit there,
they try to blame guys specifically bald,
blue eyed white males like myself, which
by the way, I'm really offended. Okay.
I mean,
and I got to tell you something right now.
If I hear one more feminist interrupting
my privilege during the day,
me just walking through one open door
after another and I have to listen to her
fucking rhetoric. I swear
to God I am. I am going to,
I will pull all of my money out of the
stock market and cause it to crash money
that I didn't earn money that was given
to me from my ancestors by stealing it
from people who did not look like me.
Okay.
Sorry,
I'm just steering into the stereotype.
MMM.
Oh really? Bill, we thought
you were fucking serious. Uh,
what am I talking about here?
This is why women,
so many of them do not attain a position
of power because all you have to do is
put on sweet Caroline and it makes them
want to tilt their head and put it on
their man's shoulder. Okay?
That is not leadership quality.
Okay?
That's just what the fuck I would do if
I was running a company right now and
God knows it be all this fucking pressure
as the guy who started the company to
step aside and let a woman run it
so you can act like you're fucking
progressive.
You know what I mean?
Where are the ladies when
it's all being built?
They're nowhere to be found
then when it's built, we want it
now that you completed it.
We want to fly planes too.
Now that all the guys died and we
figured out what not to fucking dope.
No offense to Amelia Earhart, the chick
that fucking, uh, also crushed it,
but for some reason nobody talks about it.
MMM.
I want to talking about,
I'm just fucking around everybody.
I have no problem with people of
Eddie. Fuck it back. [inaudible] but,
um, where am I? Let me, uh,
let me, let me complete this.
I have to do a fucking radio tour for
two hours starting at eight minutes.
And how long have I done in the podcast?
Is it going to work out
with a math workout?
Nine and five or 14 son of a bitch.
I still got half a podcast to go.
I'm gonna have to wait till the
end of this shit. Um, Oh bill,
why are you doing a radio tour?
Because I'm promoting rough and rowdy
going to be in Youngstown,
Ohio. All right.
There's no women. They're putting
their heads on their guy's shoulder.
They put their head in their ear to the
guy's chest after they hit him with a
fucking pen and make sure it's
fucking heart's still pumping. Okay.
I'm talking a tough town and Youngstown.
It's going to be great.
We got pride verse prejudiced.
All right.
We have a gay man who's
fighting a convicted felon
who does not like gay people.
All right?
We got a cop fighting a skateboarder
and then we've got a bunch of Cleveland
Brown fans getting in the ring
with Pittsburgh Steeler fans. Now,
God knows the browns cannot beat
the Steelers on the grid iron,
but can the people of Cleveland
beat up the people of Pittsburgh?
Now you'd think generally speaking,
the people of Pittsburgh are a little
softer than the people in Cleveland.
All right?
They have six super bowl titles.
They haven't had a fucking steel
mill in generations out there. Okay,
I've gone there. It's a
tech city now. All right?
They got all the beautiful bridges.
They got rid of three rivers.
That team plays on natural grass now.
I mean,
it's one of the quaintness
towns you'll ever go to.
Nobody can walk up this fucking hill.
So they've got a goddamn elevator
trolley thing that brings you up.
I think Pittsburgh is ripe for the taking
and uh, go to rough and rowdy
brawl to order the fight.
I'm telling you right now,
hang with your recorded or hanging
that night with your buddies. Watch it.
It's going to be, I will be
commentating. Forgot to mention that.
That says a little cherry in
there that I just throw. Okay.
A little fucking sugar cube. Oh, freckles.
We'll be sitting down on his
lack of an ass evidently. And uh,
I'll be there with the big
cat in the El Pres. Uh,
two wonderful individuals, you know,
who are preventing a lot of bar fights.
I feel, I feel like, um,
people with headgear and gloves are
going to be able to get all their
frustrations out. It's going to be
a wonderful night of entertainment.
I am not going to miss a
second of it. And um, you know,
I would appreciate if
you guys would order it.
It would make me look good if I could
help pump up their fucking numbers.
I love what they do over there.
I hope you do too. If you do,
please order the fight and that's the
end of this promo. How do you like that?
And right the day before the fucking
fight, I'm going to be in Rochester,
New York home,
Steve Gadd,
or at least he played with the
Rochester Crusaders according to his,
according to his drum instructional video
of that I actually own on VHS and on
DVD. All right. I never could
commit to the laser disc.
I was afraid of unpopular technologies.
After Robert Kelly talked me
into getting a mini disc player,
which I still have with the t shaped
microphone. I can't find the chat,
but I have all these little
fucking cassettes of, uh,
you know
what happened?
Many cds of my sets from years gone
by and I want to listen to them.
And people are like, well, why don't
you take him somewhere? It's like,
cause I have no idea what I'm saying
on these fucking things, right.
I used to mutter to myself between sets,
thrown out all kinds of crazy shit
and in this fucking today's climate,
God knows what, what the, the
shit you said fucking I'm,
when we're at 20 years ago,
I mean,
20 years ago I was dating this woman.
I used to literally drag around the city
by her hair and nobody had a problem
with it.
Okay.
You think I'm going to dump off my
fucking mini disc player to somebody's
Yeti mind?
It's not happening. All right. Anyways,
so I am a, hey, by the way,
guess what? I made another month,
month of July, not a drop of booze.
Not One fucking drop.
You got damn cuts and uh,
it really affected my mood.
I was in such a good mood when
I would wake up in the morning,
but I was so grumpy at night, you know,
just having to sit there and fucking
stare at the wall. Um, I,
it's weird like this, this time of day I
don't miss it, but at night I definitely,
you know, you know, you get into
with your wife or a, I don't know,
your parents looking
at you in a weird way.
You just need something to take
the edge off and I got to tell you,
resent a stone. French just
isn't doing it. Um, all right.
Do I get time to do one read?
Yeah,
I'll do one read and then I
got to do this tour and then,
then I'll be back and I'll let
you know how it goes. Okay.
Everybody hanging on my every word, GI
bill. How is your radio tour going to go?
All right,
here we go.
He looks everybody Helux maybe I can
get through this in three minutes.
That'd be fucking great. There's
nobody on the planet like you. Oh,
so why would you buy a generic
mattress built for everyone else?
What do you the hunchback
of Notre Dame there. Next,
please mention all the talking
points below. Oh, absolutely.
He looks sleep matches your body to the
perfect mattress so you get the best
sleep of your life. Why? Why?
They've developed nine
different mattresses tailored
to specific body types and
sleep preferences. Just
go to helix. Helicase
sleep.com/birth take their two minutes
sleep quiz and the match you to the
mattress that that's perfect for you.
Contouring to your body,
cupping your balls,
squeezing your lack of an ass to provide
unprecedented comfort and better sleep.
36% of helic sleep customers report
better sleep after switching to their
customized mattress from helix sleep.
Uh,
right now they're offering up
to $125 off all mattresses.
Mattress artists,
whether you're a side sleeper,
uh,
hearts
like a plush or a firm bed, they got
the mattress that will fit just right.
Get up to $125 off he looks.
sleep.com/burr that's helic
sleep.com/bar for $125 off your mattress.
Order Helix, sleek.com/. Burn.
All right, quip everybody.
All right. The truth is most of us
are brushing our teeth wrong. Oh good.
How are you doing?
Not long enough and forget to change
our brush on time. Former
porn stars, gagging on it.
That's because most brands focus on
selling flashy gimmicks rather than better
brushing but not quip.
So what makes quip so different?
You may not have asked. Uh, please
mention I'll talking points below.
Of course I'm going to quip
as an electric toothbrush.
That's a fraction of the cost of the
bulk of your brushes while still packing
just the right amount of vibration to help
clean your gross teeth. You listening,
England quips built in timer
helps you clean for the dentist.
Recommended two minutes with
guiding pulses that reminds
you when to switch side.
Next crypts. Subscription plans are
for your health, not just convenience.
They deliver a new brush heads on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just $5 including
free shipping worldwide.
Quip also comes with the amount that
suctions right to your mirror and unstucks
to use as a cover for hygienic travel
wherever you take your teeth. Uh,
and finally,
everyone loves quip.
Evidently they were on
Oprah's Olis I love is
named one of the Times best inventions.
And is the first subscription electric
toothbrush adapted by the American Dental
Association. Excepted. Sorry, now it's
already eight 45 but I had that happen.
Plus they're backed by a network of
over 25,000 dentists and hygienists and
hundreds of thousands of happy pressures.
Use Quip everyday.
Quip starts at just $25. And if you
go to get quip.com/pro right now,
you'll get the first refill pack for
free with quip electronic toothbrush
electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill
pack for free@getquip.com
t Q u I p.com/ [inaudible]
spelled Ge Tq, uip.com/burr. All
right, I'll be back in a second.
All right, I'm back. The radio tour
is over. Let's finish up this podcast.
Oh look,
the last read,
but it do do beyond these B and e's.
Finished my radio torb Du du Du
to beyond [inaudible] beyond ease.
Get the boy shorts,
you whore.
Yank him up your ad spend over the table.
I'll frigging bang.
You're like,
I'm Clark Gable with my
ginger mustachioed face.
Um, from the freckled race. I'm
really pasty. All right, me undies,
everybody you've heard me
obsess over my me undies.
You've heard me talk about how they are
softer than cotton and come with fun new
prints each month. But I've got a big
scoop for you. That's disco a scoop.
I just literally fit picture just
like up you shit your pants. Uh,
that I'm so excited to you.
Shit. You me undies. I'm a
Newbie undies with the shit trap door
that I'm so excited to share with you all
me unease just gave them math membership,
a massive upgrade.
All those dirty old
whole written disgusting
underwear you've hung onto.
It's time to throw all of that
out and give you a top drawer.
The refresher it deserves.
Each month Mandy's,
we'll release a new executive
print that only members can get.
Can you imagine all this skid mark to
underwear that's going to be thrown out
because of this promotion. These could
be collaborations with artists, brands,
or other unique designs. You're going
to definitely want to have members.
We'll also pay less for everything on
[inaudible] website with special member
pricing. That means if you want
a second pair of undies, a,
I don't know what, there's a
braille it, B, r. A. L. E. T. T. E.
I don't know what that is. Or lounge
pants. You'll pay less than anyone else.
The membership comes with no strings
attached. You can switch styles,
skip the month or cancel at any time.
You're going to love these Sundays.
They're the softest
underwear you ever put on.
And they come with fun prints that
you can match with socks or a bright.
What the fuck is a Braille
lit? What? Here's up, bro.
I gotta look this up right now.
Braylin Braylin
[inaudible] hey, by the way, uh,
the show in season one on me,
TV of a 77 sunset strip.
I can't wait. I missed the first couple,
but I got, I got episode six. You know,
it's crazy. Oh, is that Brilinta? The,
how do you say it? How
do you say it? What?
Say you bro. Look, I'm so dumb.
There's no okay. Pronunciation,
pronunciation, acetate. Here we go.
Come on. Come on. We're allied
or allied
Brown.
Light Brown.
Brad OLED. All right, I
got it. All right. Okay.
They come with fun prints that you can
match with your socks or your brown.
Let they come with 100% satisfaction
guarantee. If you don't love them,
just send them back.
Gross for a full refund.
Me On says a great offer for my listeners
for the any first time purchasers.
Uh, when you purchase any undies, you
can get 15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on.
And who knows? Maybe someday you can
match them to your Brown. Let, um,
no, I can relate. Yeah, I should know
about Ai. Yeah. Brown. Uh, all right,
so let's see here.
I did nine minutes than I did 13 minutes.
Now I've done four minutes.
Nine in three is 21 and 425 I've got
about another five, six minutes left.
Now the five, six minutes
left. Oh, Billy glueless.
So anyways, I have, I haven't drank in
like, oh, what did he sit here? A 30,
33 Larry Bird and Larry
Lynch, 33 days. No booze.
Woo.
Um, and uh, yeah, I have
really had no intentions.
I'm going to drink one day next week
celebrating with the Joe de rose.
It's Jody rose his birthday on August six.
Make sure you give all twinkle
toes a little shout up. All right.
Make sure you get that little
saloon whore a little tippy,
you fucking cowboy hat day. He'd love
to hear from you. Um, Joe by the way,
is really an incredible
inspirational speaker on a,
have you guys seen Joe de Roses?
Uh,
Instagram when he has,
he's sitting there shirtless with
awful bodies. Like it always goes.
What's up hard bodies.
Jody,
Rosie here telling you that you don't
have to be a slave to your diet.
I Dunno. Just look up at Joe de
Rosa or is it at Joe de Rosa comedy?
Just look up Joe to Rosa Instagram.
Maybe I can do it for you.
I'll make it easy for
you because she spoke.
You're probably pretending to type right
now acting as though you're working. Uh,
Joe de Rosa Instagram.
He's on the gram. Oh,
and I'm not connected to
the fucking Internet course.
Why would I be, why would I,
in this day and age be
connected to the Internet?
It's just most of the free world is
most of the free world is right there
connected to it. They're connected.
They're connected to the know. I don't,
let me type this in here.
All right,
Joe Away. Rosa. Instagram.
All right GRANDPA.
It's at Joe de Rosa comedy.
E D e R. O. S. A
comedy. Um, Megan, why don't,
why am I hyping his
Goddamn Instagram page?
What does Joe de Rosa ever done for me?
Other bench other than being being
a pal for the less fucking 15 years.
Um, all right. What
the what to talk about?
I was just promoting rough and rowdy by
the way. The cop first to skateboarder,
that fight is actually,
that one's called pig verse punk.
So you get pride verse
prejudice, pig verse punk Ed.
Uh, where could you go from there,
Paul Luca versus [inaudible]
it old boxer fight.
Say a politician.
That could be a good one.
They should have just sort of an uh,
an endless ones with,
with the letter P. Huh?
You could have a,
somebody with a bladder problem.
Peer Verse Poor.
Go with a bladder problem.
Fight somebody who's a
economically in the shit.
I don't know. Okay. Maybe there's not an
endless one. I Dunno. Maybe I'm wrong.
I'm just spit balling here people, that's
all I'm trying to do. Just spit balling.
So anyways, I got to, uh,
I'm going to go see a nutritionist for
the first time ever tomorrow and uh,
I'm going to get that taken care of.
I did the lat pull down
machine 70 fucking pounds.
Gradually I'm putting it back
together the way it really happens.
Not like on Dr Phil where
he's like, yeah, oh yeah.
Or Nay to stop punching her in the fight.
And like somebody who I would
actually, yeah, punching a in the face.
The fact that he said that like it's
going to get rid of everything that he saw
as a child in that moment on Dr Phil,
stand out works. That's going to be,
it's going to take that guy an entire
lifetime to stop punching women in the
face or shooting heroin or jacking off
in public whatever the fuck it is he
stealing. Right, but not all Philly.
Philly makes it seem like he solves it.
Right then in there with the little
fucking catch phrase is some bullshit.
That's why,
you know,
back in the day when I used to watch
police academy and I would see private
hooks number, the cute little
black girl, you know what I mean?
It should be all mousy. Like,
yeah, he hit that guy again,
the guy you got to get a scream and then
in the end she get her nerve up and she
jumped out of nowhere with a gun out
and she goes, don't move dirt bag.
And then you'd see police academy to
when she'd go back to being this little
mousy person again. You're like,
what the fuck? That's bad writing.
That's what I thought.
That's lazy,
you're going to have to do the exact same
arc all the way to don't move dirt bag
again. And I used to think
that that was lazy writing,
but now having tried to,
to fix,
to control my temper, flip out, be
like, I don't want to do that again.
And then I'm fucking, you know, working
on or working on or working on and I'm,
I'm good for three weeks and then
I, I have a relapse. You know,
private hooks is one of the
most accurate characters ever,
ever written because you
seeing somebody trying,
they have a breakthrough and you think,
is this it that I finally break through?
And then, uh, nope, it was
just a blip. Now you're going
back to being mousy again.
And she had to work on it through
like 1819 police academies.
And I don't know if she ever got there,
but I think we all could relate simply
by the fact that she was just out there
trying. There you go.
So that's nine minutes.
Nine minutes in 13 minutes. That's
31 minutes. Jesus Christ. People,
I think I'm done here.
I'm back up to regular volumes.
Tune into the red sox, Yankees.
Do you want to check that out? Um,
but definitely this Sunday, man,
make me look good.
Make it seem like I drove some
traffic to this wonderful event.
Go to rough and rowdy brawl.com
to watch pride verse prejudice.
Pig first punk and Cleveland Brown fans
trying to do with the browns have never
done on the, which is beat
something from Pittsburgh. Ah, Bell.
Why did you have to be mean? Because
you know what? It makes people listen.
All right.
Enjoy
music.
And then we'll have another half hour of
greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon
podcast just before Friday.
Monday morning podcasts from a Thursday,
gone by from years ago, or possibly
last month. I don't know how it works.
God bless you.
Have a great weekend.
You con and a two and then
I'll be dressed in shabby.
I'll be in Youngstown
for the first time ever.
And everybody else see Rochester New York
on Saturday night with the Great Dean
del Rey in the opening slot.
All right.
God bless you in the
United States of America.
Yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
like a boss.
It's like the beginning
of fucking $6 million man.
You know when that little
fucking kite that he's flying,
why don't they ever show
that fucking show in reruns?
That's one of the greatest goddamn
shows ever. Do you guys ever see that?
Do you have any idea how fucking huge it
was when the $6 million man fought the
$7 million man
[inaudible]
and he punched his fucking
face off his face came off
[inaudible]
on television in like 1974 do you have
any fucking idea? Think about that.
Pre Internet,
pre cable,
pre any sorta special that you look
how bad the graphics were in Star Wars.
The adjustments between frames of all
the tiny moving parts are minuscule but
projected at the proper speed.
24 frames per second.
These individual movements
will flow seamlessly together.
[inaudible]
actually models which can be
carried in the palm of your hand.
So this is like three,
four years before that Lee Majors Punch
this dude who was the fucking bad guy
and everything.
Oh Man.
Do you remember the one with the $6
million man fought? Fought in the snow?
Yeah.
Your first
Karen as an expert and a French art
I'll set up outside that mansion.
They had everybody in slow motion in that
black dude jumped like 10 feet in the
air was going to kick him.
He's gone
flying through the fucking air.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
well you got to stand how
sheltered I was as a kid.
I didn't even know who Bruce Lee was.
I didn't even know what Kung Fu fighting
was and I didn't realize that TV shows
were ripping off,
you know,
enter the dragon and all that shit
that people were flipping out about.
Cause I was just a little
kid. So I saw that shit. I,
it was the most unbelievable thing ever.
He fought big foot.
He fought a black Bruce Lee and he fought
the $7 million man and he punched his
fucking face off and a tele.
They just don't, they don't make,
it's impossible to compete now. There's
just, they've just done too many things.
You know, it's kind of like when you go
to write a movie script and like, oh,
everything's been done and they act like
all these guys back in the forties and
fifties were brilliant.
It's like fuck you.
There was only like five
movies where ever made,
how hard was it to be brilliant back then?
It's like inventing shit and
eat and the 1800 oh look,
it's a coat hanger. You can
hang your coat on it. Holy Shit.
Let's put his name in the history books.
Everyone can fucking remember
this for the rest of the time.
I don't even know what you could event.
You always great.
It's still inventing a simple shit.
Is that Billy Mays guy?
You know that bear did fuck every night.
He just starts swab. Billy Mays, I,
Billy Mays here for the Jupiter Jack
the most can be in hands free device for
any cell phone guaranteed.
That dude,
he doesn't even event the shit.
I think he invented like three things
and then he's just got a sweat shop of
like smart fucking kids from Thailand.
He just comes walking in.
I keep borrowing and myself on the iron.
Come up with some shit.
Then like three weeks later he's on TV up.
Billy Mays.
Are you doing tired of burn their hair
off your forearm or your art in your
button down?
Cause your third marriage didn't work out
and you still have to date in your 50s
hey drug dosing,
the fucking thing you stick in front of
the iron that doesn't burn your forearm
but still irons the
fucking shirt. Um, anyways.
Oh let me get, let me get back to
this thing. Sorry. Huh? See like that.
There you go. I want to stand up. Mo
gave you some fucking laughs. Okay.
And his left eye. What does his I do,
it's like a zoom lens on a camera.
A Zoom Lens.
Amazing.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
it's like a boss.
So anybody watch 60 minutes.
This past week they did a,
they did this feature and that feature
on mountain lions and now California is
the only state that has mountain lions.
Just walking around.
Los Angeles ended suburbs are
home to 19 million people,
the only mega city in the
world where mountain lions,
also known as cougars and Pumas
live side by side with humans.
For 13 years, the national park
service has been studying the animal.
Uh, I'm going to fuck
this up in a, in a park,
I guess maybe the size of like
Griffith Park or Runyon Canyon or,
or whatever those ones are
out in, uh, out in the valley.
P 22 wanders the hills of Griffith Park,
a small enclave in Los Angeles,
frequented by hikers and visitors
to the parks. Famed Observatory.
I guess they have these fucking
things. And um, so anyways,
I was watching it because a few of the
places where I hike with my dog and this
thing has intermittently this,
this,
this group of fucking mountain lions has
been around there. But fortunately they,
they try to avoid you,
I guess
a trail camera caught this one. A stone's
throw from the rooftops of suburbia.
And these animals do their best to, you
know, stay elusive and away from us.
Um, at least during the day
if they're not fucking hungry.
But they showed this fucking, uh, these
people, these mountain lion, right.
Okay.
They were having some work done.
So they had somebody going underneath
the house into the crawl space of their
house and they all ran up against this
park and the guy went down there and he
immediately came back up and
he was fucking like white
as a ghost and they were
like a dawn, the A's, you know,
fucking white people trying to
speak Spanish. Right. Oh eight. Um,
is it French? I don't know. Um,
and a guy comes out of the fucking hole
and was like, yeah, man, I fucking, uh,
is a mount line down there. I just came
faced tonight, get outta here. You shy?
And they will let, he's like, yeah,
it's fucking down there. And so anyways,
they interviewed this fucking La couple
and they had the quintessential fucking
la couple, a mountain
lion in your house, Bro.
I'm sorry you said that. All the
melee and he goes, yeah, man.
Face to face, eye to eye came out
of I with any music. Terrified.
You know what I mean? He looks like
the leading man of a B movie. Right?
She's got like bleach hair.
She's
wearing fuck me pumps. She's on 60
minutes. Where in fuck me pumps.
It's fucking hilarious. Walking
round, done up to the nines. And um,
I actually, uh, was pretty cool. I was
trying to figure out where the house was.
I Google mapped it and I
think I was able to find it,
but I'm gonna fuck this state is so
fucking insane with the droughts,
the fires, the rattlesnakes, the
coyotes, the mountain lions, you know,
and everybody's in this place. It's so
phony and so plastic. Well, you know,
it can get, uh, that can all go away
pretty damn quick with the wildlife.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's built borrower and it is the
Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
August 2nd, 2010. Oh my God. Martha,
can you believe it? It's already
August. Could you believe it Martha?
Actually,
I cared Karen because it was
just July in my entire life.
August has come after July,
so yes,
I can believe that it's August 2nd.
Why do you have to do that?
Do what that, you know,
why can't you just,
you know, have frivolous
conversation. Why do you have to pay?
Why do you have to be such a cunt? No,
I'm sorry. Well that's what's your big,
um, anywhere. Oh Gee. Oh Gee. Oh my God.
What the fuck did I do last night?
I was going to do the podcast last night.
That was the plan.
Boys and girls,
ladies and gentlemen,
children of all ages.
I was going to do the podcast last night.
I was going to upload this motherfucker,
midnight my time,
you know, for all my friends
out there and the fucking, uh,
Great Britain out there in
Ireland and Iceland, you know,
that'd be like eight o'clock in the
morning for you, right? You get up,
you people in Iceland throwing down some
hay for your fucking JAKKS taken out
your pan flute. Skipping
around, looking for the gold.
Isn't that what you do out there? Yeah.
Well that's what I think you'd do.
Cause I took geography in America.
So you know what's up Holland? How's
your windmills? Ah, you're clicking.
Your fucking wouldn't shoes together.
That's my version.
That's my version of Holland.
They don't even have cell phones out.
Their cell phones is still using
pitchforks to get their point across.
Um, that's an even make sense.
But what did I do instead?
You know, this is the classic
life of the loser, all right?
And if you are a loser,
not saying you are, okay?
Hypothetically,
if you are a loser,
you're going to recognize this pattern,
okay?
And this is the pattern of the loser.
They'll see the loser knows what
he or she is supposed to do,
and the, and, and then you
never do it. And that is a
pattern of a loser. All right?
Did they make any fucking sense?
It started like I was going to make this
huge fucking point and then my headache
really just kicked in there.
But let's, let's try it.
Let's try to put the wheels back
on the cart here. All right?
Just like those people, um,
out there in Finland right now
and all the people down in
fucking Australia wrestling
those poisonous snakes as
the aborigines fucking
sit there with that.
That white God damn tooth
sticking through their nose.
You know that shark tooth that Greg
Brady had around his fucking neck when he
was going to be the next Johnny Bravo.
Huh?
Just sitting there fucking staring
at me. They're aborigine, man.
You think I need that shit?
You think you think I'm the one who
kicked you off your fucking land?
I'm a Goddamn indentured
servant to the fucking banks.
They're half naked aborigine dude. All
right. To Stop fucking staring at me.
All right with your Thong.
You fucking sad face. All
right. I didn't create plastics.
I'm just dealing with it.
Why don't you show me how to fucking
join whatever it is you're thinking about
rather than fucking judging me.
And by the way,
could you help me with this fucking
snake over here? Um, anyways,
this is what the loser does.
Um,
yeah, I, I was gonna, I was,
I was going to do x, Y, and Z,
but instead I did fucking d and f
fucking idiot.
Instead of doing the goddamned podcast,
I went out and I drank last night.
Oh Gee,
I wish I had two whiskeys.
And to Miller highlights.
Why did I have Miller highlights? You
know what? Because the bottle looked good.
I like the way the bottle look.
It's one of those nights there's a
shiny looking bottle. I like that.
I'm going to have that.
I'm going to block out those fucking
awful Miller highlife commercials.
I hated those commercials.
That fucking plumber with his greasy
fingers picking up that deviled egg.
It's like, are you trying to stick
Budweiser? Right. These fucking ads.
All right.
This is just anger.
Just of frustration at myself.
I don't know why I did the things
I did last night. I shot pool.
You know like I'm fucking Willie Mosconi.
You know that's it. Yeah, we don't,
we as a man,
you just walk up to a pool table even
though you know you suck and you're just
thinking it'd be like, you
know, seven ball corner pocket.
It's going to fucking go right
in and never goes in. You know,
just like your life.
You think it's on target.
You think it's heading
right towards your weight,
where you want it to go and Bam
bounces off the fucking wall.
And next thing you know, it's all the way
on the other side of the fucking table.
This is ridiculous. I shouldn't be doing
this right now. I resent, I'm resenting.
I'm blaming you guys. I'm fucking blaming
you sitting in your Goddamn cubicles.
What do you think about that?
What do you do?
He can't fucking do anything about it.
Are you going to send me
fucking emails complaining?
Yeah. Well I don't give a shit. I
don't fucking Ivy had breakfast,
Jeff sitting in my pajamas doing that
thing. When you're hung over, you know,
we just sort of rub your feet together,
trying to give yourself some sort of
soothing feelings on the other end of your
party because your fucking head
is throbbing so much. Well,
maybe I can offset the headache with a
soothing feeling between my footies and
of course it's not working.
Oh Fuck Jesus Christ.
Two whiskeys and two bears.
I feel like I fucking, uh,
I dunno. Like, I dunno what,
like I had a fight in the
parking lot and I lost.
And last thing I remember was somebody
grabbing my big ears and bouncing my head
off the asphalt as I'm going, I
write a right, you won, you won.
And then you just slip off into a dream.
Ooh. Do, do, do, do, do, do.
Um, you know, it's weird. I woke up
whenever I wake up, hung over. Um,
you know,
one of the first things I do is I just
start cursing out the woman in my life.
You know, this is my remedy
for getting over a hangover.
You know, you wake up and
you see them, you know,
and you're trying to get the fucking,
you know,
that goddamn cement out of the eyes
is you're trying to open them up.
And of course, because you're hung
over and you want to be alone,
the vibe you're putting out is you
want to be alone. What happens?
You create,
you attract what you fucking fear.
Not only another human being
right in your goddamn face.
It's gotta be a female.
Okay? And God knows,
can they ever stop running the yaps.
It's like even when they
don't have something to say,
they're gonna fucking talk because
as much as they talk a good game,
I'm an independent woman and I got my
money, mother Fucker, all that shit.
At the end of the day,
all these broads are afraid of the
same thing. They're afraid of silence.
That's what it is.
You know that when you watch one of
those goddamn shows or in my life,
you walk by and your girls watch
and one of those goddamn shows.
Why and why am I bringing my voice down?
Like she's still in the apartment?
She isn't, but you know what? He just
want to bring my voice down here. This is,
I'm either talking about the Illuminati
or I'm talking about these fucking
bitches. Um, this is
all hangover talk here.
So I'll fuck all you guys if you're
taking this seriously. All right.
Rule number one,
or is it number two at this point?
You don't fucking take the podcast
seriously. Okay. Oh, you girls out there,
you get your panties in a bunch. It's
ridiculous. Why does he make fun of men?
Well, it is the balance it out
because that's life sweetheart.
And Life isn't fair.
Why don't you go listen to one of those
fucking 2012 podcasts with the fucking
broad over there running her goddamn
yet between her cleavage. Ah,
why don't you go do that sister town
with your tampons in your purse just in
case. Whew. I am in a mood.
Um, yeah. So I'm sitting there and I
got fucked. They're afraid of silence.
Stay on target.
They are,
they're afraid of silence. And that's
why they talk about nothing. Oh,
that's what I was trying to say.
You walk by the TV and your girlfriend's
sitting there, right? She do. You know,
sitting there on the couch right in the
couch side saddle. You know, they sit,
leaned up against the arm
with their legs to the side,
rubbing their footies together.
That of peeking out of the Afghan.
What? I like this show.
You Watch your shows.
Do I say anything when you're
watching your shows? I don't.
So why didn't you extend?
Shut up.
So, you know, you walk by the fucking TV,
you walk by the Goddamn TV and what
and what is it? What is on the TV?
You know what?
I don't even remember.
I don't even know what the fuck
I'm talking about. Oh yeah.
They're just running their yeps. Oh
the, I got it. Here we go. I'm hooked.
Backed up to it.
There we go.
There was a little awkwardness
there like you ever see when, uh,
when a jet tries to refuel in mid flight,
you know,
and that Shark Dick is hanging down.
I know what a shark Dick looks like.
What do they think about that?
Is that scandalous enough to get on
TMZ and my low level of notoriety?
I do.
I was watching this fucking a nature show
and these fucking creepy humans cause
that's what we are.
Pull this great white shark
out of the fucking sea.
And the sharks lie in, they're like, I
can't fucking breathe over here. Right.
And they got this little garden hose
going into his mouth and it seemed the
shocks looking like,
really this is the same as in h isn't
fucking hailing a mouthful of ocean,
your little fucking true value hardware
garden hose that you got my fucking
mouth. What are they doing?
Get away from my deck please.
And they literally reached down
and between a couple of faults,
they pull out this shark cock,
which amazingly enough
looks just like the fucking,
uh,
that,
that tube that they refuel in the
air for with or whatever the fucking
preposition. Is that a
preposition? I don't fucking know.
Trying to complete a sentence over here
and that's what it looks like. All right,
there you go.
That Porsche was dedicated to all
our troops over there in Afghanistan,
in Tuscaloosa, um, in as a weird thing
of sitting in the airport. The other,
I'm going to get back to the broads.
I'm going to give them a break right now.
Okay. I, I tried,
I tried to knock them out in that
round and now I'm fucking winded.
I'm taking around off. Is this starting
to score points? I'm just giving them,
I'm just giving them hope.
Taken a round off,
but I'm coming out with the next one,
um,
foot in a glove in their face like Larry
Holmes and I'm coming with the overhand
right. My favorite fucking
thing in boxing. Um, ah,
God,
what was I just talking about?
I was talking about Shark Dicks and
then I have to shark dicks. Oh, I know.
I'm in the airport. All right, good.
This is just going to be all momentum.
I'm going to just try to not stop talking
for 50 minutes because when I stopped
talking, the throbbing in my head
is actually audible. All right.
Slow it down, Bill. Let's take it
down a little bit. A little fucking,
some fucking smooth jazz here. All right,
so I'm sitting in the fucking airport.
This was an awkward thing, right? Uh,
all these troops came walking by and
these people spontaneously started to
applaud, you know, and I
didn't know what to do.
Do I join in?
It just didn't seem right.
But then you don't want to not
fucking show your appreciation,
but applause just seems weird.
It just seemed weird.
And I was trying to put myself in
their fucking position. Like, you know,
you just came out of Fallujah,
did what you had to do over there and
then you get fucking however it works.
Next thing you know you're on jet blue
and you land at an airport and there's a
soccer mom. Whew. Good game. Good game.
You know, I don't know what to do.
Definitely appreciate him. But,
so that's for the troops out there.
Do you want applause in the airport
or is it fucking weird? You know,
cause we don't want to do that shit that
happened to the troops when they came
back from Vietnam and all those
fucking hippies were like, hey man,
that was cool when you burned down that
dudes hut me and we don't want to do
that, but I don't want to
have an overcorrection,
you know where you're like Dan [inaudible]
bed in it in it is that fucking song
they played up. I'm trying to think of
like college football songs, you know,
here come the troops,
but Aminah bomp bomp Bam.
In order to want to go, he had a Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
You don't want to go like two high energy.
There's gotta be a happy medium
between sitting there being
like, oh, the leaves are brown.
And then sitting there,
you know,
applauding like somebody just sank a putt.
It just didn't seem right.
All right,
so anyway,
so you walked by the TV and
there's the in the broad's always.
They're always talking
about how much more, uh,
I guess how much, what better
communicators, females are,
which I've probably proven to the last
fucking 14 minutes of this podcast.
Um,
and now he did know of a woman
actually says 20,000 more words a day.
Then a guy does serialize that
yet. Do you think? I didn't notice.
I thought it was 40,000 more.
Okay. Let me tell you something.
They have fucking sink hole.
We
just, because you're saying more words
doesn't mean you're saying anything.
All right.
You basically filler buster your way
through silence with your girlfriend
because both of you are sitting there
afraid that if you stop talking,
you're going to hear the sound
of your boob sagging. All right?
Oh yeah. Well that's what I think it is
in my own fucking ignorance. All right,
let's get on with the podcast
here. People, I'm sorry. I had to,
I had to do a little cardio there just
to get myself through the first 15
minutes, you know, now I can
fucking chill. So I woke up,
hung over today. Obviously, man,
I'm attacking the broads because I'm
hung over and for the most part I don't
like them. Um, I like to look at them.
I like to come over and stick my dick
in them, you know? But after that,
it's like, why don't you get out in the
kitchen and make me one of them fucking,
we'll log the sandwiches
when she just fucking love to be that guy.
You know?
Just find some little fucking
mouse of a woman to live with.
Just blame your entire afternoon on her.
Where the fuck is a fucking room up?
Oh,
you had it last. What the fuck did
you say? I guess it was my fault.
This is terrible. This isn't even
comedy anymore. This is just mean.
So I woke up this morning,
hung over as I've mentioned 98 times.
And for some reason I woke up and uh,
this song was in my head. I just
woke up. But this was the song.
It was in my head right here.
Yeah.
Hung over off my ass.
And all of a sudden I just hear Elvis.
What's your woe? Shake me
your big hitch. Oh Hoo.
That's one of the greats fucking
songs by Elvis Presley and a,
when you really listen
to the lyrics, um, it's,
he's a fucking psycho.
He stuck in this broad hot in the kitchen.
Holly in the whole,
let me go a little dude, you're
headed all because, well,
saw kitchen and the kitchen kitchen in
the kisses starts a team of wild horses
couldn't pull us apart.
He's singing about rape everybody.
But he gets that. Oh, and it's
yet, it just smooths it all out.
And that's why he was the king.
Only the king can make rape seem,
uh, like it's, it's the right
thing to do for both parties.
Let's just be clear on that
for both parties. All right,
let's get on with the podcast. Okay. I,
I fucking love that song.
I really do.
And I was working the Orleans and a casino
with Tom Papa in the marriage. Refs,
Tom Papa.
Um,
I was coming out on stage like that
and I felt that for half a second.
I felt like 1 million bucks.
If I have a fucking second.
Can you believe it's
August? Um, all right.
So let's get on with the podcast.
Last week, ladies and Gentlemen,
I had the pleasure of performing on the
David Letterman show and most of you
went out, you watched it and you all
sent me wonderful emails about it.
And I would read you the wonderful emails,
but they're not funny,
but you are in luck.
You know what ones are funny?
The ones where people did
not like my performance.
So let's read a couple of those,
shall we?
All right now I fucking nose is
running. Okay, here we go. Here we go.
I did a little coke last night.
Everybody know, never had the balls,
never had the balls to
mess with that shit. Okay?
Uh, this is, uh, this is
somebody and I was always, um,
for those of you whenever I read
my hate mail, um, both of these,
the two hate mail emails that I
would be reading this morning,
all of a sudden I sound like right now
like a teacher teaching a really boring
class. You know that year and F, you
know, first class of that semester,
right? You finally get yourself
a little bit a poon Tang.
You're happy, you're floating around,
everything's going to be great.
You're thinking, okay, let's see
all my teachers are going to be,
and then that douche comes out.
Well,
going to meteorology in the media.
My name is Mister Kahn
face and Mr can face what?
I'm in third grade. I'm sorry, I'm
hung over. I couldn't come up with,
my name is Mr McGillicutty.
Now,
over the course of the next three months,
we're going to be that way against all
the wonderful world of meteorology in the
media. You'll be required to
write two to 27 page papers
on theorists,
clouds in the Dakotas.
Okay.
So cirrus clouds were first discovered
ever since the Hydrus via that,
whether they love and they
picks up the fucking marker,
please writing across that fucking bored.
Sir Makkah is largest
Catholic yet the third,
uh, at first, before I said
mark is the Catholic author,
they thought a cirrus clouds.
We're actually the God's sake
that your wife was account.
I've got nothing. What's the breathing
and knowing it was supposed to be? Um,
all right,
let's read the hate mail here.
So what happens with all of all of my
hate mail is when people don't like my act
is you can't just write me evidently
and just say that you don't like my act.
You don't appreciate what it
is that I do on the stage.
What you have to do first is you have
to establish what an incredible sense of
fucking humor you have and how open you
are to all different forms of humor.
You know, it's that classic thing
like those douchebags on Youtube.
Obama is a fucking idiot.
And I'm a Democrat, right?
Yeah.
So then we can be like,
wow, this guy is left.
And even he doesn't like this lefty guy.
So this is what they do. All
right, so here and so these uh,
both these emails follow to a Goddamn
fucking t did the mother fucking UNV
um, they follow it here at it.
They follow that pattern bill.
Just read the fucking thing. Okay,
here we go. All right. Hi there.
Oh, this one starts. Starts
off. Nice enough. Hi there.
I've been a fan for awhile.
You seem to have a unique take on things.
Look at this, Huh? Pat
me on the head, but me.
Sniff her hand making me
nice and fucking relax.
I loved your bit about the muffins
and the mass vehicular murder.
So there you go. She just
showed how we, it just,
her sense of humor spans the globe,
whether I'm attacking food are actually
running over human beings on the
sidewalk.
She finds it all funny though.
And here's the rub though.
As a stay at home mom,
I now completely despise you.
I did this bit about being a
stay at home mom. Um, so anyways,
she says the hardest part about being
a stay at home mom is being respect is
being disrespected by everyone.
I now hope the worst for you,
despite what funny acts you
may think up in the future,
you are a jerk and deserve the
worst that life has to offer.
I don't fucking, I don't, I
don't understand like these,
this is a classic fucking person where
everything is funny until it comes around
to some shit in her life and I make
some fun and some shit that she's doing
being a stay at home mom and now all of
a sudden she goes from being a fan of
mind to now I am a jerk and deserve
the worst that life has to offer.
That's, that's a fucking
hard courts that you deserve.
The worst that life has to offer. So
what? I'm going to get leprosy and uh,
be constipated all at the same time
and fucking survive a plane crash,
but not in a good way, you know?
Anyways, I don't fucking know really.
You're going to take it to that level.
So I wrote her back and I said,
a sweetheart,
Oprah Winfrey called your job
the toughest job on the planet,
on national television,
and got an applause break of approval.
How much more respect do you need?
I think that's a great point.
If I can step outside the email,
break the fucking fourth wall.
Is that what it is? The third wall? I
never knew what the fuck it was. Huh?
Oprah Winfrey's on TV saying you have
the toughest job on the planet and
everybody claps.
All right.
Did she say being a standup comedian
is the toughest job in the planet?
You think you know what it's
like to be fucking disrespected.
You Apron wearing sheltered
son of a bitch? Huh?
You want to talk about being disrespected?
Looking fucking comedians anytime
they show a comedian in a movie.
Is it a Chris Rock level comic?
It never is.
It's the fucking hack with the
lampshade on his head going Wakawaka.
Right.
Then the fucking comedian gets
shot in his gut during Scarface.
Ah,
did a fucking stay at home.
Mom gets shot in the fucking stomach with
that Mr. Potato head mask on her face
during that show. No. You know why?
Cause she was at home taking
care of the fucking kids. Ah,
Jesus Christ.
I'm just gonna read the rest of the email.
I didn't even fucking make sense.
It started off funny and then it just
went right off the rails like a Prius that
you can't fucking stop. Um,
anyways, uh, she says, so I wrote,
I wrote a, how much more respect
do you need? And then I said,
meanwhile there are children
working in sweat shops.
Would you rather be a stay at home
mom or an eight year old sewing Adidas
together for 16 hours a day?
I came up with another great example that
I, I wish I had used on TV. How about,
how about you work on one
of those fucking oil rigs?
Like those poor bastards
who worked for BP.
Then all of a sudden out of
nowhere the fucking thing explodes.
You standing on a metal structure in
the middle of the goddamn ocean and next
thing you know blows up,
probably blew out both your air drums.
He had deaf now and you're on fire.
All right?
And your only option is either burning
to death or jumping off of basically the
equivalent of the top of a brownstone
trying to enter the water without
doing the biggest flaming belly flop,
right?
You land in the water,
second and third degree burns
in salt water. All right?
Pus and blood is oozing into the water
and now all you can do is pray to God
that the coast guard gets there
before is see as sharks eat you alive.
All right?
You want to do that or you want to
watch Bob the builder for the 800 time?
Lighten up. And then I wrote, Oh,
and don't despise her
hope that works for me.
That causes premature aging hugs.
I know that was kind of mean to say,
but you know what? Go Fuck Yourself.
All right, here's another one. Once again,
we have to establish credibility
at the top of the email.
Are you guys ready for the credibility
to be established? Jesus Christ.
I know I am. Here we go. Ah, Bill,
I am never appalled or capital letters
offended by comedy that I see in here.
All capitals. This sentence,
I have a great sense of humor.
Wow. This is unbelievable. Isn't
that amazing podcast listeners,
this person is never appalled or offended
by comedy that she sees or hears.
She has a great sense of humor.
She is such a great sense of humor.
People that she had to
yell at at me and emails.
All right, so tis no way. She
had a problem with my act, right?
Let's read the rest of the
email, however, oh gee.
Your appearance on the David
Letterman show that I just watched,
just put down women and motherhood
to an extent that is just downright
unbelievable. Dot Dot. Dot. Now she's
going to yell again and tasteless.
Now she yells for the rest of this email,
but I'm going to spare you guys.
All right.
I'm going to read it and soothing tones,
but she's screaming the entire time.
That's what I'm guessing because
it's all capital letters. Um,
this is what she says.
I challenge you to be a single parent
and raise a child and work and attend
college alone without any help.
Just in case you don't know what being
a single parent meets. All right?
Um,
you have no idea how hard it really is.
I am disgusted with your act and
will not ever buy any of your DVDs,
et Cetera.
For the first time in my life,
I am disgusted with comedy.
Your comedy, that is like if she
starts speaking like in film,
nor I'm disgusted with his comedy.
Your comedy that is say, Eh,
23.
Skidoo all right.
Your Act touched on many topics that you
were disgraceful and very unappealing.
I think she got so mad she stopped writing
sentences. Um, first of all, sweetheart,
I wasn't making fun of a single single
parents that was making fun of single
parents. Nobody would laugh. I was talking
about stay at home moms. All right?
You don't remember that line hanging
out all day making grilled cheese
sandwiches.
You given a puppet show,
you dress like a dragon and
then some other adult comes
home and gives you money.
You like a big kid. That's some other
adults coming home, giving you money.
Is Your fucking husband. You dumb broad
drug on a fucking spell it out to you.
So I just wrote her back. I just said
I wasn't talking about single moms.
I was talking about stay at home moms.
You weren't listening.
Well listen, I'm not going to do this show
anymore. If I have to put up with this.
I'm just kidding. I love these fucking
hate mail things and that's all I got.
I got,
I got to to uh,
bad emails and then I had one guy who
wrote like a five page dissertation on,
uh, on the shirt I was wearing under
my suit or something like that. And uh,
then I just went homophobic with him.
I just wrote a,
that's one of the gay ass
emails I've ever received. Uh,
thanks for the fashion advice.
And then he wrote back trying to act
as if I got a bunch of emails from guys
telling me to wear a carnation in my
front pocket or whatever the fuck he was
saying and he wrote this big long fucking
four page email and then I just hit
him with, come on sweetie, don't be
like that. And then it ended it. I got,
I got a lot of a little
weird emails this week.
Somebody saw a date night and said I
need to be more choosy when I pick my
roles,
which I thought was fucking hilarious.
Like someone who has eight lines in a
movie is actually getting offers around
town. We got to get this
guy. The way I'm telling you,
the way he stands next to other people
talking in the film is incredible.
He is the best at it. Yeah, no,
I got to be more choosy
with with a fucking,
yeah.
Evidently because I wasn't doing
stand up in the movie date night.
Like the role of my character was the
straight man and the more [inaudible] or I
played it, the more opportunity for the
other person to be funny in the scene.
That's your fucking job,
you know?
And I did the job and I think that
wasn't the job that I was supposed to do.
I would think that the director might
have said something and just because I'm a
fucking comedian doesn't mean I'm
going to walk around, you know,
with a lamp shade on my fucking head.
I'd love to be in a bad ass fucking movie.
What do you think I want to do?
You know, you think I want to be in
raising Arizona part to actually I would,
but I'd also like to be in a,
they can ever make a movie
as good as a good fellows.
I'd love to do some shit like that.
Play a fucking psycho.
Put the lotion in the bucket but
wouldn't want to do that shit. All right.
You dumb. Fuck am I, I don't need
to be more choosy about my roles.
I need to take anything anybody gives me,
you know,
fucking shot that movie a year ago.
I haven't done another one.
Is that choosing enough for you?
Not been up guns.
Not like I'm not trying. All right,
let's uh, let's plow ahead here.
Let's get on with, uh, what else
do we got going on? Oh, by the way,
if I want to thank everybody. Seriously,
I was just fucking around there with the,
uh, the Letterman stuff. I had an
unbelievably great time and uh,
that was my best Letterman
if I do say so myself.
I finally figured out the pacing
that I have to go on TV and uh,
what I always used to try to do is I
used to try to go comedy club speed,
but TV audiences for some
reason laughing clap a lot more.
And then I would,
I would try to do was plow through the
applause and get the tag of the joke in
there. And uh, I dunno, it's
like a whole different animal.
You got to figure out what do
you do when they're applauding,
you know, why did the chicken
cross road to get the other side?
Woo Woo.
Maybe that's why I didn't applaud when
the troops came by because I thought that
they would feel as awkward as I do when
you're just standing there going, okay.
Thank you. Yes, I know that was the
greatest joke in the history of the world.
I am tremendous. Where do you get
a load of this one? Um, all right,
let's read some. Um, let's read
some match. Oh, and by the way, um,
later on that night, um, in celebration,
I had the most ridiculous fucking weekend,
um,
that an adult can have and part
of most of his, because, uh,
you know, I chose what I wanted to do
in life was exactly what I wanted to do.
And secondly, I'm not married and
I don't have any fucking kids,
so I don't have any
responsibility. Hence, I, uh,
I get to live the life of a,
a gay guy.
Give me notice how happy
fucking gay men are.
You know why that is is because
they got the fucking double whammy.
There are fucking man.
So they can earn way more an hour than
the fucking broads over there and then
they don't have any God damn kids.
So once you get around 40,
if you've done grading your, your career,
you have all this disposable income,
you know,
and the only way to kill the voices in
your head that you should have had a
fucking kid by now is to go out and do
frivolous bullshit to fill up the free
time. And that's what I've been
doing. So I actually this weekend,
um, one of the things I got to do this
past weekend is so fucking unbelievable.
I can't even tell you how I even went
down, but I did take video of it.
And if you want to watch the video,
you can only go place everybody.
And that's the MM podcast.com.
Huh? You like that?
look@thatandexclusivemondaymorningpodcastvideothatwillonlybeshownonthemmpodcast.com
of course, until some douche bag
takes it and puts it up on Youtube.
So go to the [inaudible] podcast.com and
a watch a video of something that I got
to do. And, uh, I, I don't even,
I can't even begin to tell you how that
whole fucking thing went down and how I
got to do it, but, uh, was one of
the great things I got to do in life.
So I got to do that,
which I won't be telling you because I'm
trying to become a smarter businessman
here.
All right?
The only way you should hit pause right
now and go to the MM podcast right now,
if you're not following along anyways.
Um,
I got to do that unbelievable
activity. And then, uh,
what did I do?
I did Letterman on Monday and then Monday
night I went down to the bitter end
and I watched that fucking amazing guy,
Oz noy this guitarist,
if you ever get a chance,
if you ever in a New York
one Monday a night, this guy,
Oz noy goes down and he, I don't know, I
can't even describe what the fuck it is.
He does very, very unique
guitarist and he, uh,
I don't mean you got to see him live.
You have to fucking seem live as
youtube videos. Do not do him justice.
He got to go down and seem live and um,
and he's always playing with
these top notch musicians.
He had a will leave from the
Letterman band was there.
Steve Ferrone from the average white
band actually went up and got a fucking
picture with them and Shit,
uh,
from the average white band and now Tom
petty and he's played with a zillion
other people. One of my drumming heroes
got to meet him that fucking night.
And uh,
the guy on keyboards is one of the
original guys from the East street band,
but I'm not into the e street band.
But this guy was the shit and I just
watched these fucking unbelievable
musicians and sat in the crowd.
These guys were so fucking good that
actually had the comforting thought that,
you know what,
robots will never take over fully.
Robots will never fully fucking take
over because they'll never be able to do
what I just fucking saw.
I mean when he,
you're gonna write a program for passion.
God, no, some fucking egg head
with no passion is probably
figuring that shit out.
Figure out how to make a robot sweat.
Will it plays fucking guitar?
Yeah,
that'll be,
that'll be the big fucking breakthrough.
That's why drum machines never fully
took over cause it's just somebody
programming the shit. You know,
it's not a human being playing it.
Right. Is that where, I don't know.
I'm too fucking hung over
to actually have a fucking,
a fucking touching moment here in the
podcast all a couple of weeks ago I told
you guys how to dump, how to get out
of a fucking relationship. All right.
Um, and if you ever want to learn
how to not get into a relationship,
go download a Andrew dice Clay's
live album at Dangerfield,
did the, uh, the day the laughter died.
And one of my favorite bits
of all time that he does is a,
I think it's called hot n how
to not get into a relationship.
So if you don't even want to deal
with how to get out of relationship,
listen to dice Clay's bit on how to
not get into into relationship and a,
but then if you fuck up
and you get into one,
listen to my podcast from a couple of
weeks ago and I'll give you the blueprint
on how to get out. All right? So anyway,
so this brought up the
whole getting dumped
and people have been sending me emails
about getting dumped or breaking up in
the awkwardness and all that type of shit.
These are some great stories.
Here's one for you getting
dumped. Hey Bill, how's listening?
Last week and wanted to tell you
about the worst way I was dumped. Uh,
when I was in high school,
I had a friend who was a girl and I
was in love with her in a pathetic,
never getting laid way while she was
banging and half the football team.
Oh Dude, that's like that movie last,
uh, last American Virgin, right?
Then I already use that reference
on the podcast. I don't give a fuck.
I'm hung over anyways. I, after
high school graduate graduation,
we started dating even though we went to
different colleges, seven hours apart,
um,
over I yeah,
I love how she starts dating you then
because the football team left her and
went to 47 different colleges, so
she just needed a dick to ride. Um,
over fall break I went to visit her and
stayed at her place for the weekend.
On the last night at midnight,
she told me she was seeing someone else
and then expected me to stay at her
house that night. Oh, what a cunt. Um,
I got up and pack my shit
and as I was about to leave,
I did my best Brando impression
to let her know how she,
how she fucked up.
Um,
and as I started to go out the door
after making my dramatic statement,
she said,
don't you need your keys?
Yeah.
Oh, this poor bastard. He goes,
I forgot my keys on the table
all the way across the room.
So I had to walk all the way across,
back the pack,
across the room in shame to grab my
keys and then drove seven hours back to
college in the middle of a, in
the middle of the night. Dude,
let me tell you something. You
got, you got half a victory there.
Um, because you did leave
and you know, and you did,
you had the ability to walk all the
way across the room to get your keys.
And at no point during that long
fucking did you break down in tears.
You didn't. All right,
don't you need your keys?
Ugh. Ah, that's fucking brutal.
That's like, that's like mean.
Yeah.
Because you know what she thought,
I guess that you were going
to stay there for the night.
So I guess she went mean there.
Don't you need your keys?
Obviously you need your keys.
If she was trying to let you down
easy when she'd be like, mmm,
you forgot your keys here and just would
have the decency to look down at the
floor.
Don't you need your keys?
Ugh,
that this is what I want to know from
you on that seven hours drive back.
How many different snappy comebacks did
you come with for don't you need your
keys? I bet you were so fucking
distraught. They didn't even make sense.
Don't you need your keys? Don't
you need your current, right.
That doesn't even make sense. But
you know, it's something you'd say.
Aww, you poor bastard, whatever.
You know what the good news is?
She probably has three kids right now.
Our bodies looking like she's standing
in a fun house mirror and she probably
has some sort of fucking STD.
So, you know, there you go sir.
It all worked out in the end, didn't
it? All right. Uh, bad covers.
This is from back in the day
we're talking about, um, when,
when an artist comes
around like a lady Gaga,
you know,
when she comes around and
she wraps herself in toilet
paper and holds a fucking
dildo and everybody's like,
she's thinking of fashion state,
but she shocking Middle America,
uh,
holding like a black
baby while playing chess.
Is there anything worse than that?
Paint by numbers. Shock. You know,
and then, then the fucking douchebags
who cover it, just stand right in line.
She's pushing boundaries.
She's rejecting what it is to
be a woman. Oh God. Shut up.
She's wearing a silly outfit.
Isn't that what she's doing
as a fan? Blowing on her Twat,
hanging off her belt buckle.
And then I'm supposed to sit there and
be like, oh, I can't even process this.
This is cutting edge art.
I mean,
what is she really doing?
Yeah.
Oh,
good faith poke phase.
Oh my God,
I can't handle it.
This is like when Jimmy Hendrix came
out. No, it isn't. There's like,
when Cindy Lopper came up,
she braided half her fucking head,
right. And dance down the street with
their fucking shoulders going up and down,
yelling at Captain Lou, I'll bottle.
It's, it's kind of on that level.
I remember when Cindy Lopper did that
shit and then she didn't do anything.
And next thing you know, she's
on, she's on that fucking, uh,
who wants to be a CEO getting fired by
that guy who I don't even think has any
money or any Donald Trump fans out
there. I don't think that guy is rich.
I really don't. I don't. I don't
buy it. If this guy is such,
if he so fucking rich and has
all these goddamn businesses,
how does he have time to do a
reality show and in critique?
Who's better at running a lemonade
stand? Cindy Lopper. Bret Michaels
is,
is that what a fucking a
fucking whatever the hell he is. What?
What is, what do you call a guy like that?
He's, he's, he's a uh, a conglomerate.
A media conglomerate. What,
what the fuck is he called? A
A, I can't think of the word.
I'm too fucking hung over. It's not
like one of those ingenue names then.
I know it's not that way. I know
what that, that's not what it is.
A knew means you're a, you're a good
looking gore. Gore. Good looking whore.
Who Someday
my brain is so fucked right now.
I just combined good looking in horror
and she's a good, she's a Gore Al Gore.
Al Gore. Who is a bitch or your fucking
body. Al Gore or fucking Bill Clinton.
Both of them.
They're big mother and hips sachet and
around the White House with their fucking
suits on
Eaton Stouffer fucking pies.
Um, I am so off the track right now.
Um, we're talking about bad covers
now on this is,
this is,
this is what I really believe about Donald
Trump for all his fucking Trump water.
Trump tower, Trump casino,
Trump helicopter, Trump,
te toenail clippers.
I don't think that that guy,
if you gave him fucking,
if you gave him 12 hours,
I don't think that he could come up
with more than 6,500 bucks in cash.
I think he's just completely leveraged
out, but his projects are so big.
He's like the banks. Like
he, he's too big to fail.
Oh, Jesus Christ. What the fuck am I
talking about? Where the hell am I?
Let's get back to bed covers.
All right. Bad covers.
Here's one for you.
Uh,
Madonna when she did a American pie,
um, yeah, that song kind of sucked
to begin with. And then, um,
just in case you didn't realize it's
sucked, Madonna came in and proved it.
Yes.
This song did suck.
Even if you completely switch it up
and put that club beat underneath it,
it's still gonna fucking suck of Jesus.
I'm just running on a momentum,
you know? Did I really just do a
lady Gaga impression? I'll fuck you.
You enjoyed it. You
enjoyed it. You know, you,
you do a podcast hung over. I want to see
how good you do. Yeah, I didn't think so.
I didn't fucking think so. Um, here's
the youtube videos for the week.
We're just blowing through the topics
here. Youtube videos for the week. A pug.
Pug Sings Batman theme. Look
that one up there, right?
Pug as in the dog.
PUBG pug as opposed to a
Gore pug sings Batman theme.
Um,
drunk ass knock out.
A lot of this shit's going to
have to do with alcohol this week.
A wasted guy at Coachella,
Coachella is CEO,
c h e l l a.
And here's one for you,
uh, do something difficult.
And you know what?
I actually forgot the most
fucked up one of the week.
I have to just bear with me here.
I have my,
the microphone laying
on my chest right now.
I want to say somebody used to
do that didn't like one of those.
Those guys late at night when they're
trying to sell your shit before they came
up with the Janet Jackson
Mcdonald's drive through headset.
Then they have like that hands free device
with the microphone just dangled from
your neck. I want to say that
they had that. All the other guys,
that's a movie coming
out that the other guys,
I actually had an audition for that movie
and I got all the way down to the part
where the guy who got
the part was fucking he.
I think he went in before me and killed
it. So now when I see that movie,
I'm like, ah. It looks so fucking funny.
I could've been in there with eight lines.
God dammit. All right, the fucking,
all right.
What's the name of this
video woman finds man in bed,
something like that. Oh, here. Women.
Woman wakes up to find
intruder in her bed.
You got to see this one. It's so fucked
up. I don't even know if it's real.
It looks like a fucking in living
color sketch. Um, all right.
Overrated, underrated for this week and
the overrated underrated this week. Uh,
you guys really took it to another
level here. This is fucking phenomenal.
All right. Underrated. Ah,
first kid in your junior high
that admitted to jerking off.
That might be one of my favorite
underwriters of all time.
What a fucking champ that kid was.
You know,
you know some people are still trying
to find themselves at 35 or possibly 42
like myself. That kid knew who
the fuck he was in junior high.
Hey, jerking off I do it. Fucking
feels good. Fucking rub one out.
Next class. I liked the teacher. She's
still with something for me. One,
I'm the last guy in the, in the, in the
fucking row. Just don't turn around.
You'll be fine.
I'm number two.
Whoever commented that Roger Ebert now
looks like one of the muppets from the
land of video. Jesus
Christ. On a side note,
that is one of the creepiest
videos ever. Yeah, man.
Poor Roger Ebert, Jesus Christ. You
know what I mean? How ironic is that?
That he spent his life criticizing people
and then he gets fucking mouth cancer.
You know, and he's, he's still
criticized and shit. He's like,
he's like the Goddamn a terminator.
Um,
Jesus Christ. And if that's true,
what the fuck am I going to get?
The fuck's going to happen to me. All
this shit that I spew. Um, number three,
Leopold butter's Scotch
next to Cartman the best
character on South Park.
I hope I said the dude's name right.
I love South Park. I really love that.
And I'm actually, I'm going to, uh,
I'm starting to watch the boondocks
because everybody told me that's the shit.
So watch it with me. And, uh, let's
watch a quality show together.
What do you say people, anybody
else watching? Breaking bad?
I can't believe I've been watching it
for three fucking seasons and I haven't,
um, I haven't, uh, haven't really
talked about it. I fucking love it.
It's a God damn.
It's a great show.
But I've yet to get into that
advertising a mad, mad, mad men.
Mad Money. The fuck is it? I Dunno.
Everybody walks around smoking.
Um, I heard it's great. And everybody
on that show is dressed in suits,
which I like a number four underrated.
This is another great one. This is a new,
this is, this is, this is this person's
first contribution to the podcast. And a,
I think this person
should be a staff writer,
is another fucking gem number four station
wagons in the 80s with the rear seats
facing out the back window.
Kids have everything today,
but they missed out on that one.
Do you know my parents had an 83 caprice
classic maroon with the fake wood going
down the side, top of the
line, the wire wheels, cloth,
Maroon fucking, uh, interior.
We drove all the way out to Chicago
one time, all the way up to Chicago.
I was in the Middle Cup of my siblings
were sitting in the back and I was
jealous that they got to sit, you
know, seeing what we just fucking saw.
And then my parents sat in the front and
that bench seat that blocked the AC and
they wouldn't let us put the windows.
Dad,
my fucking dad would sit there with
his hands in front of the, you know,
he's hands on the event,
like an inch away from the vent,
failing the AC coming out,
you know,
completely fucking selfish. And
will they, can we turn it on?
We couldn't put the windows down.
They're like, no, we got the AC on. Yeah.
With the big cloth bench
seat is fucking blocking it.
And we just sat there looking at farmland
wisdom by my brother's actually got to
stick their heads out the
window in the back, you know,
like a couple of fucking months
and I sat there in the middle,
just had to sit there taking it all right.
Number five under rated kids in the hall.
Absolutely.
When people bring up the greatest
sketch shows of all time, you know,
they'll say Mr show,
they'll say Dave Chappelle and uh,
the people in the know also say kids in
the hall and I'd have to definitely go
with that. Alright. Overrated
humping in the shower apps.
A fuckin lutely. That's
exciting. When you're in college,
you know that sensation of water,
you know?
Yeah. Hopping in the showers. Weird.
Then the water's hitting her booty crack.
It starts making a weird noise.
You know,
as a water shoots up from
her fucking ass crack,
it's hitting you in your lower jaw,
you know, who can concentrate. Um,
number two, uh, bartenders that claim
to have created their own drink.
Is it ever good? It's
never fucking good. Uh,
overrated Bourbon Street I got to
go with yet. That is overrated.
You fucking go down there.
It's a bunch of Goddamn tourist who
can't hold their fucking alcohol.
And then there's a bunch of Goddamn
wolves on the side streets waiting to
fucking stick a knife in your neck.
Uh,
also overrated national spelling.
Bee contests are overrated.
Uh, I dunno, I dunno if I go,
I actually liked those ones and I think
it's great that those kids learn how to
fucking spell. It's something that
I wish I learned how to do and um,
I root for him.
I want him to win the spelling bee.
And I also want him to get laid before
the 36. Um, and here's a random one.
Go on Google maps and you know when you
can hit satellite then actually looked
down,
you know,
and actually bring yourself down
on the street with that little man.
Here's one for you in
the middle of France.
This is what you want to look up his,
the address eight rue,
which means Street d,
You have duct here.
[inaudible] Doc, t. E u.
R. G. R. A. N. D. J. And that
was one word, g. Uh, Grand Joel,
which means big Joel. Um, five,
four zero, zero, zero Nancy, n.
A. N. C. Y. I just realized how
long this is and now I can't stop.
I've got to give you the
whole thing. Comma, m e U R t.
H. E. You guys write this down like
Morse Code Dash e Dash M o. S. E.
L. L. E. And then Lorraine France.
L. O. R. R. A. I. N. E. All right.
Okay.
Google map that hit the satellite.
Bring the little man down on the street
and tell me what the fuck that is on
that porch.
Tell me that's not a fucking alien.
There's an alien on the porch and the
satellite cut the picture of it. I Dunno.
Who knows? It's probably a goddamn
beehive. That was a fucking way to go,
but I like it.
I think that has a lot to do to good
theme for this podcast. You know,
for a hung over son of a bitch with
nothing in his, in his, in his stomach.
Other than the two slices of pizza that
I ate at one in the morning. La Pizza,
by the way. See, you know, it was good.
Um, you know, something I just realized,
I feel like I haven't said anything
funny in the last 20 minutes.
How long ago was that?
Clinton Gore with they're bitchy bodies
sachet and around the White House.
I know that, that was funny, Huh?
The sound of their milk wide hips
hitting that fucking suit material.
Nationwide healthcare.
She's walking around the Oval Office,
both of them. Eh, you know
something I'm going to,
I'm going to vote them
that in my lifetime.
The too bitchy is that's the
bitchy is tandem. That is ever,
ever been in the White House. You know
what I mean? I'll tell you right now, I,
and I didn't vote for four,
actually [inaudible] 96 actually in
[inaudible] 96 I did vote for Clinton,
but after that I've just gone rogue
because then Clinton just turned out to be
the same fucking dude that,
that, that, that other guy,
the angry guy with the
pen bombed. All right? He,
he did the same shit. They
all do the same shit. Oh,
you fucking morons who voted for
Obama and now you're surprised.
Can you believe he's pretty much
doing what Mccain would have done?
And I'm not talking about the taxes.
Shit. I'm talking about the Afghans.
Yana fucking, I don't even know what
I'm talking about, but I'm sick.
All you douchebags bitching
about all the taxes.
Do you really think you're
going to have to fucking wars?
And at some point when all the rich
people get up from the table after that,
they fucking chewing scroll.
And when you did that,
you walked in with your buddies and you
ordered a big fucking meal and when the
waitress went up to bar,
y'all ran out the door and you jumped
into your fucking AMC Gremlin and drove
away laughing, laughing your ass off.
And that poor broad had to pay for it.
Do you know that there's
a place in Norwood,
Massachusetts called the Cafe Venice
and I did that 20 years ago and I still
feel guilty about it.
I went in there,
and I'm not going to name names,
but it was a bunch of names.
There's too many names to name and we
stood up and we were going to pay and we
end.
The waitress was just not there and we
just waited and waited and waited and
waited and I'm like,
where the fuck is she?
And then there was that
tension and there was somebody,
there was this weird laugh and somebody
out of the group walked out the door and
then there was that panic. Oh my God,
it was like that musical chair game.
You didn't want to be the last one
standing when the music's playing,
playing cause then you got to pay for
check and then we all just fucking
just bursted out the door.
And I remember,
cause it was really
dark in the cafe Venice,
I don't even know if
it even exists anymore.
And then we went out into the sunlight,
couldn't fucking see shit just running
towards something that looked like the
shape of our car.
Just that young
fucking energy that you had.
We could actually be stuffed with food
and still run and laugh and still get
away,
you know?
And we just got in the car and just
laughed our asses off the hallway.
And I immediately,
afterwards I felt guilty because I
knew that she would have to pay for it.
And uh,
this is how young I was.
I actually ordered a large
milk with my Italian meal.
I was like 18 or 19 and I was one of
those guys who just never stopped drinking
milk. I didn't stop drinking
milk until I was like, I dunno.
Somewhere in my fucking late
twenties. I used to drink. I loved it.
I loved the nice cold glass of fucking
milk. And I had it with like every meal.
And it was, you know, my first
time at 18, we're all the same.
Not realize that you're
hanging out with the adults.
I had just graduated high school and
everybody's ordering and they're going,
yeah, let me get, let me get a, you know,
some folk eleague atony with
the fucking meat sauce over,
then I'll get a fucking coke in a while.
Every is ordering coke's a bear and
blah, blah, blah. And I was like, uh, oh,
have this spaghetti and meatballs
and I a have a large milk.
And there was this pause and then,
ugh, the ball breaking began in,
it never fucking ended for the
rest of it, you know, and uh,
whatever. I Dunno what the
fuck I'm saying. What the
fuck am I saying? Oh yeah,
yeah. So they, they, we got to
fucking wars for eight goddamn years.
And then all the corporations got up from
the table, ran out to their fucking, uh,
top of the line,
bulletproof SUV.
And they drove off and yet they left us
with the tab and all you guys think that
we're not going to have to pay it back.
You think the taxes aren't coming to
fuck. They're coming. Oh, they're coming.
There you go. That was my fucking
what's going on with the world
now?
Fuck you go fuck.
Yourself's whatever. I made it to an hour.
I made another one. That's all it is.
That's all it is.
It's like the drew Carey show the last
nine seasons where they'd just go and
whatever. It's syndication
money. Who gives a fuck?
Let's just bring in some fat,
broad with crazy makeup and have drew
yell at her. When people watch it, great.
We'll all get fucking paid.
We're all going to get fucking paid hate.
Anybody read that story in that magazine?
I think it was Esquire magazine about
that guy who fucking went on the prices.
Right and like a card counter.
He, he just fee broke the bank.
He won both showcases in the 37
years or whatever. This shows the
prices right,
has been on the air.
No one has ever guessed
the exact amount of Ah,
the showcase that they bid
on and this guy did it.
And all you have to do is come
within 50 bucks or 100 bucks.
And you went both showcases.
And this guy, he fucking,
he nailed bullshit.
He hit it right on the head.
And so the point they thought
he was cheating because
everybody was winning that
day and they can't figure it out if it
was him or if it was this other guy in
the audience who was fucking tip and
people off because they were given away
cars. And I guess the price is
right, has to pay for the prizes.
So evidently drew Carey didn't think
that the episode was going to air.
So he was kind of a Dick
when he said you won both.
And then I guess they ended up fucking
airing it during like a sweeps week.
So he kind of looked like a dick,
but, uh, I guess, uh, prices, right?
People were not thrilled.
So is this,
this whole article and he's saying the,
uh,
he's only guilty of being
an avid fan of the show.
And the prices right fucked up by,
they would have reoccurring prices.
I'm re re reoccurring prizes. Like they
had some sort of smoke around there,
one of those eggs, smokers. You've
ever seen those fucking things. Um,
and he knew the exact fucking price of it.
So when he was in contestants row,
they will like the egg smoker and
somebody was like 1500 and he goes,
you know, and if you don't know the
exact prices, suddenly says 1500,
you think it's about 1500?
Usually go 15. Oh one. Okay.
Or you say 1200 to try and get the
next, you know, 300 in your favor.
He said like,
fucking a,
I'm going to go with the
1478 and he nailed it first.
Fred fucking flat. Am I really going
to go through the whole episode?
It's out there people.
But we'll have go to the [inaudible]
podcast.com this weekend I'm going to be
down in La Jolla,
California,
just outside of San Diego
playing the comedy store,
my home away from home out here in La.
I'm going to do the one down in La Jolla.
And, uh, bring your ass down
there. I got a brand new hour shit.
And uh,
I cannot wait to go down there.
I'm going to spend the fucking weekend
down there, get a sunburn on the beach,
maybe do a little golfing. And,
uh, even though I don't golf,
I just like fucking,
you know,
going out there and slowing it down
for the other cuts on the course.
And that's it. That's the podcast for
this week. God bless all he is. And, uh,
by the way, in two weeks, I want to be
at the Newport Yannick Center in Newport,
Rhode Island,
and I'm going to be at the Hampton
Beach Ballroom Casino in Hampton,
New Hampshire. Uh, I got to
sell a ton of fucking tickets.
So if you're not doing
anything for the love of God,
you and all your friends come on down,
get hammered.
If you're the waitress from the
cafe Venice, please show up.
I'll give you a DVD and I'll give you
the fucking hundred bucks with interest
that I,
Oh yes,
from fucking goddamn 22 years ago.
All right, everybody have a good week.